this video is sponsored by current hey
guys
bandit here I just want to take a minute
real quick and thank our sponsor for
this video Curtin's of which I'm a proud
member of current is an actual bank with
some pretty big benefits with no hidden
fees that could really help you out if
you're in a bind the first and coolest
benefit is that you can actually get
paid up to two days quicker than your
normal paydays so if you normally get
paid on a Friday you could get paid on a
Wednesday with current two days faster
that's not bad and let's say that new
ps5 price is announced which is a big if
of course and it's a little more than
what you had left on your paycheck well
with current don't even worry about it
because they allow you to overdress up
to $200 at no hidden costs with these
and other great perks like access to
55,000 ATM locations all across the
country
instant refunds on some pesky things
like the hold on your card gas stations
place and being able to use this real
bank account for really cool stuff like
Apple pay using these benefits
responsibly could be a great choice for
you and you don't even have to be a teen
to sign up although you might want your
parents involved in this process if your
shouldn't following my footsteps take
two quick minutes and follow the link in
the description below or in the pinned
comment on the top of my comments
section you won't regret it
and now on to the video
[Music]
what new things can be said about a game
that's over 20 years old oh my god hold
on I think I gave myself a mini heart
attack just then after more than 20
years the massively beloved Zelda game
known far and wide as ocarina of time
has been played through scrutinized
studied speedrun recreated remastered
you name it it's been done there have
been countless amounts of hours from
countless amounts of people spent
delving into this game so what could I
possibly have to say about it well and I
just want to plug a little love for the
game into this video here it had been a
couple years Believe It or Not since I'd
really played the game and I started it
over just to find potential secrets for
this video and let me tell you starting
this game is just magical if you haven't
played it in a while or ever I highly
highly recommend at least emulating the
game since basically any PC can play at
these days and giving it a go it's
really quite the spectacle of gaming and
has held high the Zelda standard for
decades now one of the reasons being the
sheer amount of content packed into this
tiny n64 cartridge including a lot of
hidden or out-of-the-way secrets that
many players like yourself or myself may
have missed along the way and before I
get into the video I wanted to announce
that I have been joined once again by
the one and only hyrule gamer who has
graciously given his voice to make this
video just that much better err hey guys
is an honor to be joining bandit once
again these videos are always a blast to
work on together so I hope you're all
ready for what we have planned today
also huge congratulations to HG on the
phenomenal 50,000 subscribers
achievement be sure to not only check
out our other 5 majora's mask secrets
video on his channel after this one but
also subscribe to him for some of the
best quality gaming content out there
and I promise I'm about to get into the
content but I wanted to clearly state a
couple more things these secrets are all
going to be accessible or achievable by
normal in-game means none of these will
require any hacks or bomb jumps or
whatever just good old-fashioned content
that was hidden from the average player
and now without further ado let us delve
into the secrets that you may have
missed in ocarina of time
first up we have the secret of the
hidden room loss of players of this
legendary game know about the Scarecrow
song but if you haven't heard of it let
me refresh your memory in game there's a
certain sentient traveling dancing
scarecrow named Pierre who you can
summon at different parts where the land
of Hyrule
actually there are two sent in
scarecrows but that's besides the point
by playing the scarecrow song which is a
song you can actually make by yourself
and have the scarecrows memorized
Pierre will appear and often times give
you easier access to hard-to-reach areas
and in some cases even unlock previously
unreachable areas it's a pretty neat
trick to use when playing as adult link
but not too many players unlock Pierre's
field potential unless you're using a
gay to find all the skull toes for
instance but this isn't the first secret
in the list the first secret is a secret
area in the fire temple that not many
people know about since it's cleverly
hidden away in the fixed camera angles
of this room again unless you're
following a 100% completion guide in
several parts of the temple there are
these big maze like rooms we have to run
around dodging giant scary balls of rock
to move forwards in the last one of
these rooms once you get linked on the
upper level of the room right when you
get to the last platform when you access
the door to leave the room if you notice
navi zooms off screen to the left
indicating a point of interest if you
know play the Scarecrow song Pierre will
spawn on this tiny platform above the
rest of the area hook shorty Pierre then
turn 180 degrees and hook shot to a
target on another platform behind you
once they're at the platform will freeze
into a hole in the ceiling and boom
secret room this room has a gold
Skulltula in it which is why a lot of
100% completion guides will include the
room in the walkthrough but it's just
such a neat secret that many players
going in blind missed completely there
is also a giant golden rupee worth 200
um rupees have you completed the tank
challenge make sure to include the
secret room in your next play for it
because let's face it you will
eventually play ocarina of time again
it's inevitable next up we have the
secret of the
the many many wooden signs throughout
the game here's some context if you're
like me and you're playing a game that
gives you a dedicated attack button well
you'll be pressing that button a lot
even when there aren't enemies around
young lovey-dovey couple showing too
much PDA attack innocent farm girl
asking you to wake up Mario stab rock
that can literally never be broken using
this method press free to hit sign
that's literally sitting there doing
absolutely nothing but trying to tell
you useful directions that you will need
in order to finish the game but slash
slash except I needed those directions
and now they are in shambles at my feet
hmm this is a problem but huzzah there
is a hidden way to restore this sign to
its oh so recent former glory
simply play the beloved Zelda's Lullaby
and presto you've got your sign back to
my knowledge this has never alluded to
or hinted at being a real thing anywhere
in the game but someone somewhere
discovered that Zelda's Lullaby does
indeed heal the broken signs that is
another way you could reset the sign is
just by leaving the area in coming back
but come on secret mechanics are the
best at number three we have buddy Hg
yes bandit hey yeah listen I was
thinking um my last one was kind of
short so would you mind if I took number
three pretty please uh okay I mean it's
your video hey great great great good
good good great thanks buddy thanks okay
so at number three we have some secret
ways to make money and who doesn't like
money am i right although the secret
isn't the most useful since you have to
have completed a large portion of the
game before being able to do it it is
still a really neat little hidden way to
make a lot of money in a short amount of
time after you've already completed all
five adult temples as adult link see I
told you you had to do a lot for this
one you are shown a very revealing
cutscene in the temple of time where the
Princess Zelda herself makes her first
adult time appearance as Princess Zelda
that is at this point she gives link the
legendary light arrows which he will
eventually use to put the hurt on the
evil King Ganondorf ultimately they do
no more damage than a regular arrow to
normal enemies and even take up that
precious magic energy whenever you fire
one but they're pretty flashy
nonetheless now if you take these yellow
glowing arrows into combat against just
regular enemies it's almost guaranteed
that they will drop a big fat purple
rupee that's worth fifty rupees so if
you're at this point in the game and you
just want to purchase oh I don't know a
replacement blue tunic or maybe some
blue fire or just flex on it and buy all
the bomb shoes you can this is a great
secret way to rack up some easy money
another really quick secret that isn't
quite big enough to be a whole secret in
and of itself is the fact that there are
a few red rupees on top of the
drawbridge that leads into castle town
but how do you get on top of there you
ask well the only way to get up there is
to wait as child link in Hyrule Field
until exactly the time that nighttime
falls and walk up the chains waiting for
the top of the bridge to rest in its
vertical position as its retracting if
you've got a steady thumb you can then
walk across the tippy-top and pick up a
few red rupees which can be a nicely
sizeable boost to your wallet early on
in the game
boom secrets number three and three
point five up next at number two HD you
can go now up next at number two we have
the secret of life-giving pose yes you
heard me correctly pose are an enemy and
several Zelda games which actually
banded at a recent theory about time
pulls into breath of the whale - and you
can check that via the link in the
description blue or on screen but anyway
in ocarina of time they appear in the
field of Hyrule and several other places
as enemies that try to you know killing
but one of the cool things this game
does with pools is it enables link to
catch them in bottles
now why would link catch a ghost in a
ball you ask to sell them of course
you see when link is an adult Hyrule
Castle Turner's are rather different and
I'm not just talking about the fact that
the people in the marketplace have been
replaced there maybe even turned into a
bunch of brainian mummies called redeads
no there's actually a merchant here that
wasn't here when link was a child seven
years in the past meet the ghost hunter
as creepy as this dude is and for as
many theories as there are about who he
may be in what's up with his weird one
red
stare the one thing we do know about him
is that he buys pose and he thinks link
is cute but that's what's a to the point
because link is actually cute this is
one of the reasons why the game includes
catching balls and balls so that you can
sell them no seeker here yet you see the
other reason is that you can also impose
you hurt me drink pose the reflexive
link will only ever do one of two things
though either drinking a povel healing
completely or it will reduce his life
force them to just one heart it's a
unique hidden mechanic that's again
never revealed to be a mechanic in game
but can be useful as a sort of healing
gamble if you're already low in health
but I guess this means link can
successfully metabolize the souls of the
dead crazy stuff before secret number
one is revealed I wanted to throw some
attention towards an honorable mention
secret that many people may not know
about it's also completely useless and
will not alter your gameplay at all but
anyway in the spirit temple when link is
in adult he gets to use adult tools and
gadgets like the hookshot and in this
big room there's a big statue of the
mysterious sand goddess which this
temple is built in worship of now you
have no reason to do this but if you
take the hookshot I mean the longshot
and pointed at the star patterns located
on the statues chest area mmm they're
actual points that the longshot can
attach to yep right where the yeah where
the stuff should be look whoever did
this at Nintendo they must have had a
good few laughs over the years like I
said this is completely useless and
doesn't get you access to any new areas
or anything it's just a regular old
pervy secret from the developers
anyway now on to secret number one take
it away mister Hyrule wow that one was
weird
but speaking of the Gerudo there's a
very interesting secret piece of
dialogue head in a way that actually is
so interesting it's pretty good theory
material if I'm being honest this one is
the secret of Milan's mother Milan the
farm girl that link befriends due to
having to wake her father up in order to
get into the hyrule castle courtyard is
shown to have a very Mario esque father
and sings a song that her
however her mother is nowhere to be
found or is she
you see if you wear the Gerudo mask and
talk to Talan who is Milan's father in
long long ranch he says something very
peculiar hey that reminds me of my wife
on second thought it doesn't it doesn't
look like her at all hey interesting
with Milan having bright red hair unlike
her dark haired father the griddle jeans
could definitely be the reason for the
hair difference furthermore and yes this
is kind of gained into fury area but
it's weird that talons first reaction is
to say it looks like his wife but then
deny it fervently if someone were truly
denying a similarity after claiming a
similarity they say something along the
lines of well maybe not or something
similar the way that he denied this
twice immediately after laying on his
wife's appearance sounds much more like
denial or like he's lying
it gets even weirder when you take the
same Gerudo mask to the Gerudo the
ladies respond kind of annoyed of linq
wearing such a mask but if you take it
to Nibiru
she says this that's odd it kind of
looks like me no not really
no I all if you look at it closely again
a very similar familiarity followed by
immediately denying resemblance twice
I'm not trying to make a fill on theory
about this but could it be that Nibiru
is Milan's mother and due to either the
disparity between hylians and the women
of Gerudo or 'no burrows desire to leet
our people she and talon had to break
apart and there deny any connections to
each other either way visit in detail is
pretty intriguing but hey that's just a
secret an ocarina of time secret
and that completes our list of the five
secret things you might have missed in
ocarina of time what did you think did
we mention something or some things that
you missed let us know in the comments
below and once again thank you so much
mr. Hyrule guy for helping out with this
one hey guys thank you so much again to
bandit for having me on this video and
special thanks to all of you for being
here we also did another video just like
this one but covering some secrets in
Majora's Mask that you might've missed I
suppose you could say it's the sequel
video as all Crean of time estimates
masks so be sure to go check that out
and thanks again guys have a good one
always a pleasure as always huge thanks
to my supporters of which I have some
new faces
say hello to Joshua our solemn Andy and
Nick see who all chose to support the
channel right here on YouTube enjoy your
new benefits and welcome to my elite
crew if you watching are interested in
supporting my content and allowing me to
make even more content click that join
button below this video or follow the
links in my description to find out how
also down there are the links to my
social media pages so what are you
waiting for come say hi on Twitter right
now and don't forget to check out
current via the link in the description
below or the link in my pinned comment
that's all I've got for this one so I
hope you have a great rest of your day
this is mass antena bandits signing out
[Music]